all right so smile is a horror movie
that wipes the grin off your face to
provide you with two hours of Terror
throughout this video we're going to be
explaining the ending talking about the
potential hidden meaning behind it and
also going over some of the creepy
details that elevate it to the next
level the film is based on the short
Laura hasn't slept and this
unfortunately has been pretty much taken
off the internet so can feature on the
Blu-ray however it follows the same
basic backbone of that but it develops
it in several ways smile wears its
Inspirations on its sleeve and the movie
feels like it's in the same vein as it
follows and also the ring both these
films featured a curse that was passed
on a someone through one way or another
and this created a Target on their back
creatures stalk the victim and over time
they got closer and closer until they
were defeated or the curse won it's very
much the same with smile and for the
first part of the video I thought we'd
explain what the entity actually is now
this is a being that attaches itself to
victims of trauma and over time it
slowly torments them invisible to others
can appear as anyone but upon revealing
itself it brings with it a creepy smile
the creature's whole MO is to weaken its
victims psychologically to the pony can
possess them fully and make them take
their own life it normally does this in
front of another person and in doing so
the curse is then passed on to them this
then starts the cycle over but there are
ways that you can save yourself if you
kill another person in front of someone
else then the trauma will pass on to
them and the curse will continue that
way rather than through you the creature
in smile has a lot of layers to it and
personally eye view is very much being a
metaphor for mental health in the movie
we discover that Rose's mother died when
she was very young and that Rose could
have potentially prevented this by
calling 9-1-1 however she didn't and
because of this her mother has been seen
as a suicide victim a therapist brings
this up as a way to explain what's going
on but Rose buries this further inside
Rose has clearly carried this with her
for a long time and it's definitely the
thing that pushed her into becoming a
therapist now the victims all die by by
ending their own lives after being
tortured mentally the monster appears as
a smiling person and I think herein lies
the double meaning people like Robin
Williams have brought attention to the
fact that those dealing with depression
rarely manifested on the surface and now
from my own experience that when I fell
down I can push it to the back of my
mind when I'm in public in order to try
and seem happy I think the fact that
it's people ending their own lives and
the mental torture that comes before
their death is evidence of the duality
in the movie A Smile is also something
that carries on throughout the film
Smiles are meant to represent someone
being happy however they've been Twisted
here to have a darker side to them yet
this is something that persists
throughout the film and it goes from
victim to victim Smiles are supposed to
comfort us but in this case of the movie
Everything Is flipped upside down so
turn that frown upside down now we even
see a scene in which the characters are
forced to smile in order to keep up
appearances at the restaurant they have
an argument but when the food's put down
they smile and act like everything's
normal well I think that there's an
analysis of smiles here to show they can
often be used to appear a certain way
rather than being sincere my take from
it is that smiles are used to mask
what's really going on and they can be
used as a way to hide hidden issues
going on internally now the curse is
passed on through trauma and the fact
that Rose is a therapist keeps the film
centered around the idea of mental
health if Beyonce brings up how she may
have inherited her mother's issues and
this trauma could have been passed to
her much in the same way that the curse
passes on to others we even open the
movie where they're speaking to a
patient call and he describes all the
things that a victim of the curse would
see without the actual curse itself he's
dealing with a lot of mental health
issues and he himself is paranoid that
something is after him however this is
actually just a mental health problem
rather than being a monster but I think
that the similarities are there on
purpose we're supposed to see how they
mirror one another and because of this I
think the film can be viewed both
metaphorically and literally Rose is
someone who witnesses a disturbing
trauma and this brings up past memories
of her mother's death this causes her to
lose her relationship with her sister
her fiance and also her job she ends up
turning to a past boyfriend and
desperately tries to put on a happy face
even though something much worse is
going on in her mind I'll be the enemies
have very much destroying the trauma
over her mother's death which the
monster manifests says early on we
discover that she kept the house and
even though it's run down she won't get
rid of it how about she Journeys out
there in order to burn it down and
finally free herself of the past in the
end though it will always be there as
something she can't escape and this is
why she's taken over by the creature
Rose's entire Arc can be seen as a
mental breakdown I love that the movie
has this double side to it she has
blackouts is paranoid hallucinates and
also breaks things it calls for Harper
ignored by those closest to her and
eventually it could be seen as something
that pushes her over the edge there's
even a little line at the start in which
her patient Laura talks about how her
grandfather died in front of her out
when she was younger this of course
mirrors Rose 2 who had a parental figure
die in front of her which clearly caused
a lot of trouble I love this metaphor of
how the doctor becomes the patient and
she starts to live through the
experience she initially dismissed now
whether you want to view the monster as
real or not it's entirely up to you and
for the next part of the video I want to
go about how the movie presents it after
Laura slits her own throat and Rose's
practice the latter starts to witness
strange things Smiles letter the film
and Laura slits her throughout an
emotion that creates a line like one
this later appears on the sheet over her
body and there's also a coffee mug with
a smile on the front of it the way the
car is filmed has is tilting upside down
so that the skyline appears like a mouth
with a face above it bitter will reach
that now Carl Smiles at her before
screaming she's going to die and there's
also a smiling family on the front of
the toy box her fiance texts her a smile
face emoji and the cat is also called
mustache which sits above a SM mouth
like a Smiler
um I said there would be reaches now
this cat is killed by either Rose or the
monster possessing her it's presented at
her nephew's birthday party which is
like some Game of Thrones level event
throughout we see flashes of her
mother's death and the movie Not only
opens on it but we get visions of it
throughout we start off zoomed in but
this then pulls out almost like we're
stepping away from it however after
hours is cursed we zoom in once more
showing how she's revisiting this after
a meeting with her therapist we watch as
he practices smiling in the mirror
trying to hide how she actually feels
the birthday party goes worse than
Calico purse and Rose once more
witnesses the creatures smiling at her
she goes to the hospital and here we see
a pain assessment tool which is leaded
with smiles at this point we get things
more in line with the ring and Rose
starts to investigate the chain this
takes her to some lovely drawings of
smiles lovely that's some some lovely
pictures of the Joker in there I think
and she's forced to turn to Joel
interestingly Jill is the person who the
curse is passed on to now next however
he has a head start on how to defeat it
she heads off from her sisters and we
catch a nephew looking at her as she
goes through a hallucination I was
wondering whether the curse would be
passed on to him and who knows if he
could pop up in a sequel Hey kid well
why are you looking out the window well
why didn't you like the video yeah you
stupid kid you goddamn [ __ ] kid dumb
kid he's kidding kids today ain't got no
respect
now from here Rose goes with Joel to
visit the only known survivor of the
curse and we see a smile on the sign for
the lobby here we learn that he followed
a similar path to Rose and investigated
the chain in order to escape it he says
that he found an instant years ago in
Brazil potentially showing the roots of
the demon I did search for demons which
originated in South America but there
wasn't any that really matched it
however if you know any then make sure
you drop them in the comments below
after going home Rose is once more
visited by her therapist who we learn as
the demon masquerading as her it's the
ultimate betrayal of trust and it shows
just how much the creature is
weaponizing Rose's mental health kind of
feel like we're gonna clear homage here
to Alien 3 and Rose decides to murder
call in order to pass on the curse
whether she hallucinates the entire
event and we get a big face off like
Nick Cage in Travolta her victim here is
important as she goes to the mental
health patient rather than targeting
someone else he never did anything to
harm her yet she regards him as being
less important than others because of
his mental health issues the fact is
that she has more in common with Carl
than anyone else and yet she still
targets him now in her defense she
doesn't go through with this and instead
she takes herself to her old house in
order to shut herself up from everyone
this is so that she can end the curse
without anyone else coming into contact
with her when she finally dies a trip
back there is very much worn down memory
lane in which he confronts her past
traumas the creature takes on the form
of her mother and reveals that it got
into her mind because it was so inviting
she was obviously weakened by the trauma
and the end that he says that she can't
escape her own mind Rose seemingly takes
control back and he douses in Flames
before leaving the house however this is
a [ __ ] lie and after going to Jail's
apartment she realizes this is just
another one of the creatures tricks
however the entire monologue she gives
is very much a saying that she puts
walls up due to her past Jill got these
walls to come down but she ran away I
honestly kind of like this being the
ending over what we get but again that's
down to my preference of the
supernatural Force being more of a
metaphor your mileage may vary on air
but either way the film reveals that
Rose hasn't actually left the house and
she sees the creature's True Form it
says it will stay with her forever and
symbolically this could mean that she
isn't able to escape the guilt and
regret she feels over her mother this is
also another reason why she couldn't
sell a house the real Joe arrives and we
sees the curses passed on we get a zoom
in on his eye and this is similar to
what happened when the curse was passed
to Rose it's very much his sort of
journey into his mind again showing the
mental health metaphor now Jill will
inherit it but he has some knowledge on
what's going on or as the others didn't
he may also be stronger mentally due to
potentially not having to pass traumas
that Rose did this could be used to his
Advantage however he has very much just
seen the love of his life burn herself
in front of him which is enough to ruin
anyone's day I would have shot her yeah
as soon as I've seen the match come out
but where we go from here who knows
anyway that ends the film and of course
love to hear your thoughts on what we
took from it comment below and let me
know and make sure you subscribe for
videos that always put a smile on that
face we are in a competition right now
giving away three copies of top gameric
on the 15th of November and all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now say that to
you message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers you want something else to
watch make sure you check out one of our
breakdowns linked on screen right now
got one for barbarian if you want a
deeper meaning on that so yeah
definitely go head over there right
after this by the way thanks for
sticking to the video I've been Paul
I'll see you next time take care peace
foreign